we're awaiting president Trump as he
heads to Capitol Hill to meet with House
Republicans and immigration in the
meantime let's have a monologue so on
other networks the Holocaust was
mentioned 12 times over three days
guess why another being marched away two
showers are they're being told they are
just like the Nazis had said that they
were taking people showers and then they
never came back Donald Trump
increasingly looks like Hitler and Nazi
Germany they are the tactics that have
been used through the through history by
the worst purveyors of pure evil
including slave traders including Nazis
including terrorists well the images
suggest those of concentration camps
families being cut apart alright and
let's not forget General Michael Hayden
stweet saying other governments
separated families to ie Nazi Germany so
temporarily housing kids makes the
United States the Third Reich and our
agents the SS but other governments does
he mean Obama's here's a Washington Post
headline from 2015 Mexican kids held for
months as punishment for border crossing
and here's the president from 2014 a
message absolutely is don't send your
children unaccompanied on trains or
through through a bunch of smugglers we
don't even know how many of these kids
don't make it and may have been waylaid
into sex trafficking or killed because
they fell off a train he's absolutely
right which is why Trump stepped up the
arrest of adults for violating
immigration laws and also busting child
sex traffickers yet no one compared
President Obama to Nazis but now they
offend Holocaust victim survivors and
Americans in charge of taking care of
these kids while they're here right wolf
if you understand the controversy I do
any comparison to the colonies yes the
kids were brought in the trains to
Birkenau right which was an Auschwitz I
speak with some authority lines my
grandparents were murdered at Auschwitz
and I my dad survived but two of his
brothers and two of his sisters were
killed at Auschwitz they were separated
were separated to go to some other
facility they were separated to die
well done wolf fact is this problem is
born from a larger broken system and now
we're trying to solve long term and
short term crisis's at once
it's like plugging a hole in a boat
while you're rowing some people saw it
coming remember when we tried to help
countries under the thumbs of anti
capitalists folks who stopped that are
now shocked to see people fleeing those
very countries and now everyone is alive
with condemnation but press for an
alternative they got nothing and we're
waiting for one something no White House
before has actually produced so we all
agree separation sucks but when faced
with child sex trafficking and a
tripling of pretend families where is
your answer instead the media uses
children to maintain the narrative that
trump is evil even as he reduces the
threat of nuclear war and with no memory
of what they reported when their guy was
president Donna do you agree that I
think the White House is saying that
this is an emotional political ploy well
first of all I looked at the president's
favorite newspaper today and this is the
New York Post yes so this change
daughter yeah yeah this is about the
separation of children from their
families and while President Obama did
have a policy that basically sent people
back across the board it was very rare
that he separated children from the
family this is a policy change that the
Trump administration put in place six
weeks ago they should change it what's
the alternative the US Chamber of
Commerce the US Chamber of Commerce
today came out with a bold statement
these are not your typical
liberal progressive papers or
organizations and everyone is saying it
is time to end this policy mr. president
let's figure out a way to have
comprehensive immigration reform
let's bring more judges to the border
let's bring more Border Patrol but let's
end the policy of separating children
from their free kids here's the issue
though if we can't separate them that's
what we do in America when someone goes
to jail you you have to separate them
and no one is offering the solution I
think we're making
wrong comparison here Dana the
alternative is the possibility being
with a child's sex trafficker like weird
like this may not be a good this is a
terrible alternative but it this is an
actually worse alternative right so I do
think there are some like specific
alternatives to change this which it
would be to plan ahead there's money to
be allocated and then try to house these
families yes yeah there or I like your
idea everybody goes back together on a
bus you don't want to be separated okay
fine everybody go on the bus and you're
across the board or if you do it again
it's a felony and you will be separated
something like that that would really
like okay look we don't want to do that
and and I agree that like the people who
are being tasked with carrying out the
six-week-old policy they don't want to
have to do it but they are carrying out
the request of the president this is the
policy and then also I do think that
there's this narrow path so Ted Cruz has
an option I guess the president probably
talked about it he'll like it yes it
just deals with this particular issue
but he might just have to be for what's
going to happen here yeah get that take
that part get that off the to get that
off the table maybe get some additional
judges because I think the other thing
is that we should talk about and it's
difficult to talk about for me I think
is it what's the asylum process
what's the bar right because it's very
easy to say okay well then I claim
asylum and then you have this huge
backlog and then you have this problem I
also think that if you're going to have
this policy and you want to own it then
plan ahead and figure out what's the
process of getting the children back in
touch with their families because the
reports of them not being able to do so
is difficult the last thing I would say
is we have to figure out a way to
collectively go after the drug cartels
mm-hmm and not each other because it's
actually the drug cartels that is
fueling a lot of this right I don't you
Jesse it's hard to defend separation but
if it's preferable to an increase in
child if you don't know if these are
real families what can you do you've got
to separate them before you find out if
it they're legitimately a family yeah I
mean whether the Democrats realize it or
not doing what they want to do actually
helps the child smugglers and no one
wants that and Ted Cruz has a bill it's
right here it's piecemeal he says
families get united we Dumbo double the
number of immigration judges and Asylum
case takes 14 days that keeps everything
together why don't the Democrats like
crying Chuck just get on
word of this Peaceville bill sends it to
the President's desk they could do that
right now but they don't want to do it
because they want to exploit it Dianne
Feinstein has religious Latian Stein
which is absolutely ridiculous
she says Border Patrol agents can't even
arrest and detain an adult with a child
illegal within a hundred miles of the
southern border what's that going to do
that's just going to encourage more
people from bringing in children into
the southern hemisphere so you know Kate
Steinle was also separated by her family
with a bullet fired by an illegal alien
felon who was deported five times and
the Democrats didn't really say much
about that so when they complain now
it's like hard to take seriously no one
wants to see family separated I don't
want to see family separated but fix the
law mm-hmm fix the law he's not going to
end catch and release that's not
happening okay Jesse back in December of
last year I don't know if you were
planning your holidays but but what
president Trump put in place back in
December was a policy that as you know
attorney general session announced just
six weeks ago was to prosecute everybody
and then find out later if they're part
of a gang part of a cartel part of a
part of trafficking what senator
Feinstein and others are saying will
keep families together is that keep them
together now as you will be laws that
say you can't and you know that well
this is a policy change this is a power
97 was as you can't hold a minor for
more than twenty days and the 2008 deal
because of the smugglers and keep the is
a simple strategy keep the families
intact and then you go through the vet
process let me get Kimberly you do it
that way you know the law and you know
yeah and I think you know there's really
a concerted effort to distort really
what's going on here for political
purposes I mean at the heart of it
people do care about children we care
about families but you have to
understand how we arrived in this
position which is people breaking the
law and even if we put them on the bus
back who's to say that they're not with
the sex traffic and you return them back
with that person what we're at least
trying to do here in
responsible way in a careful way is
identify who the child is the minor who
is the adult accompanying the child and
make sure that in fact there is a match
and that they are a relative and
properly should be in that person's you
know I guess like custody so to speak
and you know a parental rights this is
very difficult I have a hard time though
accepting that it's okay to demonize ice
agents and Border Patrol and the
president of the admission all saying
that they're mean-spirited and they want
children abuse or Nazis or Nazis and
cages and all of these things I mean
this is a very tough problem that's why
immigration is important for them to
address in a responsible way but again
the laws must be upheld then there must
be some procedure by which they are
identified properly so as to not make
mistakes can you imagine the outrage if
we went ahead and let somebody go with a
sex offender and really encourage and
we're acting essentially in concert
aiding and abetting sex trafficking how
irresponsible the United Stated can
about children they just let him go with
anybody and then the child god forbid
ends up raped or tortured or murdered or
something like they should have zero
tolerance on that let me let's go to
Donald Trump he had some comments today
regarding this issue and the media bias
regarding it those who apply for asylum
legally at ports of entry are not
prosecuted the fake news media back
there doesn't talk about you they are
helping these smugglers and these
traffickers like nobody would believe
that when countries abuse us by sending
their people up not their best we're not
going to give any more aid to those
countries why the hell should some day
they're gonna vote for Democrats because
they can't win on their policies which
are horrible
their only policy was that Donald Trump
is a bad guy hundreds of millions of
dollars of negative ads nobody's ever
been hit like that I used to go home I
started disliking myself and it's hard
to believe
but gentleman bob Corker Orrin Hatch
Lamar Alexander John McCain Susan Kawa
Pincess I mean I have a whole if
identified solutions Cruz yes but do all
the ones that are now doing the outrage
signaling all over Twitter who are I
won't mention the politicians names now
they're all outraged signaling and
they're all so solemn about it but they
don't they have the first part they they
hate it which we all do the second part
what do you do about it
silence members she just listed they're
all supporting the Cruz bill well that's
good sorry look well first of all I want
to go back to what you said at the top
of the show American slavery in the
Holocaust they were absolutely evil
events and and while people often use
them to describe the pain or describe
the degradation and dehumanization these
were absolutely evil events what people
are saying now is that they think that
this compares to that I tell people
don't do it except don't go there but at
the same time we have to call this an
outrageous act because these kids are
being abused well I don't know separated
from their families right if someone
comes across with a minor they're only
separated for a day that Nana apply for
asylum that's going to take longer than
twenty days and the law says based on
the clinton ministration and upheld by
the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals you
can't hold a minor longer than 20 and
that's why he lowered it to 14 and what
the Obama administration got whacked for
was they were sending these young kids
to sponsors or uncle's somewhere within
the interior of the United States and
these kids were being abused made to
work slave it was rare though but it was
happening and that's what we're going to
take and that's the most important thing
taking care of these I have to take care
to tell what I'm trying to figure out
what is the solution that prevents the
separation again I'm just trying to
figure this out because if 10,000 people
if 10,000 of these kids are
unaccompanied they're already separated
so that leaves two thousand so what are
they doing now like
now when someone crosses with a minor
yeah and there's no prior history of
anything like that and they're not
claiming asylum they detain them for a
day prosecute them reunite them with the
kid and then send them back right but if
you apply for a process that's a process
that's gonna take them forever asylum
cases to the parent to the president
needs to understand that this is a
crisis that he can resolve tonight what
about everybody could actually resolve
it there's the Republicans know the
president he has the pen well he's the
first guy to actually try and that's
what do you mean I first got actually
try it like I mean this is I mean people
have tried comprehensive immigration
reform before yeah particularly I think
this particular issue is directly
related to a porous border correct it's
a strategy yeah fortunately is a
strategy to try to get a compromise and
this is a bad strategy well you can
disagree with their strategy but you
can't disagree with the fact that this
this guy is trying to trying to tighten
the border we all know that we have a
problem
yeah comprehensive immigration reform we
need it I agree see we can all agree
here let's go for drinks